خرصان في قلبه هجوم اوكراني مضاد اجبرت
قوه الروسيه كما يبدو على الدفع بمزيد من
المقاتلين هناك للحفاظ على موطئ قدم على
اطراف المدينه
جرائم هالو سكان بلده نوفاسبورايفكا ثلاثه
ايام للمغادره وتم ابلاغهم بان عمليات
الاجلاء ستصبح الزاميه اعتبارا من اليوم
الخامس من هذا الشهر
امرت سلطاته خرسه التي نصبتها روسيا سكان
المدينه بالمغادره على الفور تحسبا لتقدم
متوقع للقوات الاوكرانيه ودعت انها تستعد
لمهاجمه سدك خوفك الضخم عند منبع نهر
النيبرو بهدف اغراق المنطقه وهو ما تنفيه
كاف
لدينا
القوات الاوكرانيه يمكن ان تستخدم اقدر
اسالي بالحرب والتي يمكن ان يكون لها
تاثير على المدنيين وهناك ايضا معلومات
السعاده الجيش والاوكراني مناطق واسعه في
شمال المقاطعه منذ سنه هجوم مضاد في اواخر
شهر اغسطس الماضي وحتى المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون سكان خرسا على مقاومه محاولات
نقلهم وقالوا ان موسكو تريد اخذ المدنيين
كرهان واستخدامهم كدروع بشريه